[Music]  Selena Gomez then the weekend enjoy  another night out together keep my hands  to myself a source tells ET Selena and  the weekend showed up to tenant of the  trees in Los Angeles on Thursday night  check out this pic Selena hanging with a  pal DJ Ally Till's and here's the  weekend with the venue's owner and get  this the pair enjoyed an impromptu John  Mayer and Dave Chappelle show second  eyewitness tells et Dave started em  singing around 1:00 a.m. and at one  point tried to hand the mic to the  weekend to sing Selena and the weekend  first sparked romance rumors earlier  this month  I'm in a good spot right now  [Music]  you  [Music]